Ylä Areena.
Tai sanonut väärin, ja niin on nytkin, mutta tässä on tullut tämän päivän nuorisoille niinkun tämmönen näyttämisen paikka, että mitä hullua keksitää, ja sitten, ku sen saa vielä tonne näytölle, että kaikki kansa sen näkee, niin ei voi muuta ku ihmetellä tämmönen vanha käpy, mutta kyllä vanhemmilla on semmonen paikka, että pitäis vähän opastaa näitä nuorisoille.
Vaikka ne käy niin ylikierroksilla, mutta eiköhän niistä kihaa hyviä kansalaisia tu, niin kuin aina. Hyvää päiväjatkoa.
Nuoriso ei ole pilalla, mutta kirkko kuulema on, jos sinne vielä päästetään oopperalaulajia ulisemaan.
Futis puolestaan on pilalla, jos ei huligaaneja pistetä kuriin, ja kansan edustajat ovat täysin pilalla, jos eivät laske tuoppejaan alas ja keskity tekemään töitään.
Muun muassa sellaista mielipidettä luvassa tämänkertaisessa jaksossa, nyt heti välittömästi seuraa televisio ja radioasiaa.
Ensimmäisessä puhelussa viestiä ei ole suunnattu pelkästäänä nuorille, vaan ihan kaiken ikäisille, yleläisille.
Sekki niinkut nyt sanottua, kun ne jatkuvasti koila puhuu, sekä nuoret, että vanhat ihmiset, niinku niinku niinku niinku niinku.
Miehillä on parta niinku vuoriuohila, ruma tupsu leuanalla, ei oo kumma, jos maailmalla naurovat suomalaisella. Hyvää yötä pimeytä.
Karja ja radiota ja jotenkin hirveän omituista, kun ihmiset puhuu nykyään, et joka sanan jälkeen tulee äää.
Täällä on edäs huolestunut kansalainen. Minua huolestuttaa semmoinen asia, kun radiossa soitetaan tätä levyä, suroinen myrkyn keittäjä.
Siii on karmeat sanat, minun mielestäni, ja sit sekin tulee mieleen, että jos joku vielä noudattaa tätä neuvoa,
mitä, mitä, mitä, mitä tää oli tää myrkyn keittäjä tehnyt, jolleki ihmiselle, niin se on erittäin huolestuttavaa,
että joku voi olla vähän mieleltään sairas, ja rupee sitä toteuttamaan elämässään.
Niin, että pitäis pikkuisen miettiä, että onko siinä mahdollisuus olla, että ei soittelee tommosia levyjä.
Voi olla, että ei ole mahdollista, mutta tuli vaan mieleen, että siinä voi olla, voi olla semmoinen vaara.
Joo, no niin, toivottavasti jotain tehdää asia hyväksi. Hei, hei.
Kuule, ihmettelen tommoista asiaa, ku tossa radiossa. Tietyllä kanavalla tulee 24/7, kymmenen minuutin välein samat kappaleet niitä.
Eikö sinne voi laittaa jotain muita kappaleita soimaan sitten niitä? Niitähän on miljoonia niitä, että nämä samat kappaleet soi.
Ja sitten sinne saadaan myös semmoinen toimittaja, mikä myös puhuukin välillä, eikä vaan nauhalta näitä kappaleita.
Ois kyllä tarvetta. Kiitos, hei.
Kansaradio.
Marcus, täältä Raisiosta.
Mitä kuuluu Raisioon nyt tänäs unuta?
Elmetin lämmintä on aina.
No nii, joo.
Ja sit tämmöisestä asiasta, kun esimerkiksi tää jalkapallo selostuu, niin saiva selosta ja mies selosta ja...
Ku siellä saa joku maali, niin se on mielipuolen huutoo, et siitä puheesta ei saa mit... ei sit saa mitään selväkään.
Okei.
Nyt sinne tämmöiset on valittu.
Mutta eikös sitä tapahdu sillä tavalla, kun maali tulee, että siinä vähän kontrolli lähtee?
Niin, semmoista suoraa, semmoista mielipuolen huutoo.
Pitäis ottaa rauhallisemmin, kun maali tulee.
Pitää jollain tavalla, et sit pitäis ottaa selvääkin siitä puheesta.
Siiä sama laine selostaja on tämä nainen, se selostaa näitä suunnistustilpailuja.
Silloin jää semmoista mielipuolen huutoo siinä, ku tulee tiukka kamppailu siinä viimisellä maalisuoraa.
Joo, joo, joo, nii siinä kun innostuu, nii sitten ei enää oo artikulointi ihan sitä.
Nii, semmoinen liitte tehtoo lopputilii, tommosella.
Tää tommosella sieltä ei mitää, hirveätä mielipuolen huutoo.
Nii.
En tiedä, mennääkö ihan heti siihen, et lopputili, kyllähän voi tietysti kehittää taitoja.
No sit sinne, vaan sit jynssäämää lattioita.
No, kuitenkin nii.
Sit to sama on, yks vielä tämmönen, nämä tausta äänet.
Ja.
Eik nii, kyll, nykytekniika on ne pois saara, ku ei sit selostajan puheesta tahdo saaraa mittää selvä, ku se hirveä tausta meteli.
Voi olla, että moni ihminen kumminkin haluaa kuulla sen tunnelman stadiolta.
Nii, mut et oks se enemmistönä se, ku haluaa kuulla se most meteli?
Hyvä kysymys, sitähän pitää ruveta äänestämään.
Käsi pystyy, ketkä on mitään.
Kimmäsist asioist, nyt tällä kertaa, paljon olis asioita, muita.
Kiitoksia teille.
Minä, kiitän, ku soitit näistä aihesta.
Morjes.
Valikoiva katselija on laittanut meille sähköpostia, ei tykkää siitä, kun televisiosta tulee murha- ja draamaohjelmia, ne vaikuttavat negatiivisesti ihmisten mielenterveyteen, ne voisi poistaa.
Nytä ei ennen ole ollut tai tehty.
Esimerkiksi, että se ja se henkilö teki historiaa, voittamalla MM-kisoissa X määrän kultamitalleja.
Historiaa ei tehdä.
Historiaa tarkoittaa kaikkea mennyttä aikaa nykyhetkeen saakka.
Esimerkiksi, jos kopautan vasaralla pöytää, se kopautus on heti kopautuksen jälkeen historiaa.
Arvoisat toimittajat, historiaa ei tehdä, sitä tapahtuu koko ajan.
Jos mennyt historia rajattaisiin nyt menneeseen viikkoon, niin kuunnellaanpa, että mitä sen aikana on tapahtunut, mitä mietteitä herännyt, missäkin päin maata.
Eli taas on luvassa kierros ympäri kotimaan, ja hangosta lähdetää liikkeelle.
Sitä sais enemmän irti. Moi.
Täällä yksi mummeli satakunnasta. Soittelen tämmöstä asiaa, ku ostin tässä sokeriton, karviais, poisemaria, keitoa, ja sitten siinä oli plus kuitu.
Ja aamulla, ku laitoin sitä puuron päälle, niin katselin, etteihän siinä oo mitää muuta ku ihan niinku sileetä, mehuvaa, eikä roskaa, ei ollu, mitä siemeniä, eikä mitää roskia niinku joskus oo.
Ni mimmosta tämä sitten on, ja tämä valvonta, että eihän tässä mitää kuitua oo, ku mun mielestä siellä pitäis olla jotakin niistä marjoista.
Mutta tota, minä ovisilii ja vanha aikane. Ja tuota, tuli mieleen vaan sellaan, että tämähän oo huijausta.
Ja sanoivat, että ku oli mansikkahilloo, ja tuo.
Sitte savolaispapparaine oli valittanu siitä, että ku ei siellä oo yhtään mansikoita, että tuota, ni o, kaikki vaan kokonansa pelkkää välpaikkoa.
Että tota, tässä on vaan tätä välpaikkoa, kokonansa. No nii, tämmöstä, heippa.
Koitaan suomesta huomenta. Oon ihmetellyt näitä kirkossa uilisijoita, opera uilisijoita, vaan mitä hylijää, niinku kolmekymppi maksaa se kirkko maksun, ja on se törkeä hinta.
Ja kirkot ei kuulu, minun mielestä, näille opera laulajille, eikä rimputusmusiikin laulajille.
Se on hiljentymisen paikka, eikä mikkää näihin ranketredjeen paikka. Tätä mieltä minä oon. Tämä on jatkunut jo pitkää, ja aina vaan hinta noussuu.
Tää on se kummelista. Rööväyksellä ei oo mitää rajoa, eikä näillä, mitkä antaa niille luvaa ja vuokruvaa nää tilasta. Vaikka ne ei oo tämmöstä uilisemista varten. Tehty eikä suunniteltu. Tätä mieltä minä oon. Epparalla, hei hei.
Ja, joo, tämä Tervolan pappa on tehnyt, osa havainnut, osa sanoo ratiossa, että sun keskipohjan välanma punkit tulosa. Mutta kyllä niit on täällä Tervolassakin o näitä punkkia.
Että näin ylläne, sen osa oikasen niille lääketieteille. Tänä Tervolassa on punkkia. No joo, ei muutako hyöä jatkoa, ja ootelahan voittoja, musa veikkalut.
Kansanradio.
Eihanko ihmisvastaaja?
Ihan ihmisvastaaja, kyllä vain.
No, täältä Itärajalta. Terve.
Terve? Mitäs Itärajalla tänä sunnutaan?
No, mitä? Tuo pohteikyyditys täällä tietysti harmittaa, kun pohde on kilpailuttanut paikalliset taksit.
Tähän heillä nyt on niin halvempaa, tuli Oulusta oikein yrittäjä, joka kumminkaan ei meitä kuljeta liikuntavammaisia.
Liikolopulla eikä iltaisini.
Niin, tosi huonoksi meni tämä meidän kuljetus, että onneksi on tuttuja taksimiehiä, jotka sitten hoitaa näitä asioita.
Mutta eihän se oo sitten ollut se tarkoitus, että, koska pohde on ottanut, niin heillähän pitäis mitä kuljettaa sitten.
Pohjais-Pohjanmaa hyvinvointialue.
Kyllä, kyllä, näihän se tietysti mennei, kun sana tarkasii et.
Mutta ei ole riittävästi kuljettajia.
Niin, on kaksi autoa, ja kummalakin kuljettajaa, mutta heillähän on tietysti lakisääteiset vapaa päivät, ja sitten, kun ovat lomallaan, niin on vain yksi kuljettaja.
Niin, useampikin ihminen kyytiä tarvitsee.
Kyllä.
Onko siis sellaisia tilanteita, ettei yksinkertaisesti pääse sitten lähtemään kodista?
On, monta kertaa on jäänyt kuljettuunen eteiseen oottamaan, autoa ei tullutkaan, ja jäänyt monesta tilaisuvesta pois.
Monta kertaa.
Huono homma.
Ja tämä on ihan yleistä täällä.
Aattelin, että sille pohteen edustajalle soittelen tästä, mutta tämä nyt tuli niin karvastelee, kun eilettäkin ootin taksia, vartitunni tuolla pialla, eikä tullut.
No, sitten soiti sille tutuulle taksimiehelle, niin hän sai semmoisen ramppiauton, jolla minä tuolla sähköpyörätuolilla pääsin siihen autoon.
Ja se onneksi meni sinne pohteen laskuun, mutta se on tämmöstä kerjäämistä.
Etukäteen jo meinaa, menää hermot, ku tietää, että ei välttämättä koko kyydistä tuu tai reisusta tuu mitään.
Totta, hirveä epävarvous.
Jo, nii se, juuri, nii.
Et, tämä nyt on minoo niin harmittanut, ku eilettäkin tosiaan näin, usein harmittanut, aatelut tässä saatiassa, mutta nyt tuli niin suoraan tämän numeroteiltä, ja napsuttelin puhelimeen.
Kiitos siitä sulle, hyvää päivä jatkaa.
Ei, minä toivotan mahdollisimman hyvät kesäjatkot kanssa.
Kiitos, moi.
Edellisen viikon puheluista, se jossa kehotettiin työttömiä poimimaan marjoja, se herätti ainakin jonkun verran mielipiteitä.
Lisäksi saatiin vielä muutama puhelu niistä yksistä lenksuista.
Lexa puolesta on laittanut tällaisen viestinnettä, siellä kun joskus ihmetellään maitopurkkien korkkeja,
niin eikö ihmiset todellakaan tiedä, että kun korkin avaa ja sitten kääntää sen oikein napakasti ikään kuin yli,
ni se napsahtaa ja pysyy kokonaan auki, minusta hieno keksintö.
Kansanradio.
No, Anne, täältä, näijät hämeistä.
Semmonen niin tärkeä asia, että kun tässä nyt nähi eläintön ja kalastusviuttus on puututtu,
niin nyt mulla on sellainen asia, mitä missään minä en oo kuullut tuotavan esille,
että kun kala, kun se on kysymys tästä urheilukalastuksesta.
Kun kala ei voi huutaa kivusta, niin sen takia sitä ei niinkun ole otettu käsiteltäväksi sitä,
että miten kala kärsii, kun sitä väsytetään sitten, ja mukahallitusti ja sitä.
Sen takia, jos kala voisi huutaa, niin tästä pidettäis varmasti kovempi halohuuto.
Ja tämä ei oo tullu minun mielestä koskaan missään esille,
että kala ei voi huutaa, vaikka mitä sattuisi.
Olisikohan se syy sitten tuossa?
Ja, kyllä, kyllä pitäis keksiä jotai muuta harrastusta,
ja tämä ei oo harrastusta, tämä on eläinen kiusaamista,
että ehdottomasti kielettöä pitäisi olla.
Tarkoitat tätä, että pyydystetään kala ja sitten päästetään se takaisin.
Niinkä, ja sen muka hallitusti väsytetään.
Millä lailla sen voi hallitusti väsyttää?
Sitä minä en voi, mä ite en kyllä kalastaa,
kyllä perheessä onkin ollut kalastajia, mutta ei kalan rääkkää,
ja kyllä, että ei, tähän pitäisi, kun se kala ei voi huutaa.
Se on se mun, tää asiani, ja sitä pitäisi puuttua siihen.
Ja kun kala nostetaan, niin sitten se nostetaan ja käytetään elintarvikkeina.
Aivan, ja koska se ei oo mitään urhe, sen urheilukalastusta niin sanottua,
niin ei tarvi urheilla eläintenkustannuksella, eläintenkärsimyksellä.
Ehtä ehdottomasti kielot tämmöseni.
Kielot semmoseen?
Niin, semmoinen on mun mielipide.
Minä kiitän, ku soitit tästä aiheesta.
Jo, ei muuta.
Hyvät suunnuntaita.
Jo, kiitos paljon.
Kiitos, moi.
No, Martti, tässä tervehtys.
Suosta rupesin puhumaan tuosta, ku puhut, ettei suomalaiset poimen mukaan marjoja.
Ni se oo höpö höpö hommaa se, että kyllähän ne poimii, ku niitä maksetaan tarpeeksi.
Mä ite poimin tuota, tyymävuona toista tuolatta kiloa puolukkaa.
Puolukkakaverinen, seittäkötä vuotias, ni poimii kaks tuolatta kiloa.
Mutta ku hinta oo oikea, ni kyllä suomalaiset poimii.
Se on turvasta sanoo, että ei poimita.
Siksihän niitä, näitä ulkomaalaisia poimijoita halutaan, maksaa nii pientä hintaa.
Ei muuta.
Kiitos.
No hei, tältä periferiasta, huusennesta marjastuksesta, sanota, että työttömät marjaan.
No, kyllähän työttömät varmaan moniki lähtis marjaus, niille järjestetäs kuljetus ja opastus.
Se on eri asia, nää ulkomaalaiset marjan poimijat, joille marja firmat järjestäneet autot ja asunnot ja opastuksen ja ylöspidon.
Että he voivat ympärivuorokauden melkei olla marjassa.
Mut suomalaisilla on muutakin elämää hoidettavana, ja ensinnäkään eivät suomalaiset edes välttämättä tiedä, missään marjoja.
Pitäis ehkä järjestää semmonen yhteiskuljetus kunnan ja muiden toimijoiden toimesta, että ihmiset pääsee marjaan jonnekin halutessaan. Kiitos, hei.
Eläkeläinen Itä-Helsingistä kysyy tai ihmettelee tätä keskustelua näistä pyyhkeiden lenkeistä tai lenkkien puuttumisesta.
On oman kohtaista kokemusta, kun asunnossani tai koko talossa tehtiin viihtyvyysremontti, niin tuota, ei keittiössä oo yhtään koukkoa, mihiden käsipyyhkeen esimerkiksi laittaa sun muut pannulaput.
Ett, sellainen, en nyt viitsi mainostaa yhtiötä, mikä oli tän viihtyvyysremontin tehny jo, tai siis, ainakin keittiökalusteltyössä.
Ei muuta, päiväjatkoja ja hyvää kesää.
No heka, tässä Ittelasta. Se on Raksi, se mikä on siinä pyyheleunassa se lenksu.
Sitä sanotaan Raksi, Raksi.
Kaikkien muiden ohella meille tänne viestijään laittanut nimimerkki, ei ihan vielä holisti.
Voi älyhoi, ei eduskunnassa etene mitkään eläinsuojeluasiat ynnä muut.
Tärkeät, alkoholia vaan kotiin ja alkotauki sunnuntaisin.
Siinäpä taas nähdää ratkaisut kansalaisten hyvinvoinnin kannalta.
Kuka näistä päätöksistä hyötyy?
Alkoholistit ja, tulee vaan lisää ongelmia.
En enää äänestä ikinä ketään.
Eduskunnan jäsenet istuvat ihan turhaan persuksillaan ja tienaavat.
Turhia sanoja, turhia lupauksia.
En vaan millään ymmärrä näitä päätöksiä.
Terveisin siis, ei ihan vielä holisti.
Nimimerkki ärsyntynyt katselia.
Jos pääministeri ei tiedä, eikä ole ottanut selvää, mitä hän on päättämässä, niin onkohan henkilö silloin oikealla paikallaan?
Ja samoin koko hallitus.
Kyllä muualla maailmassani ei ne tule selittelemään televisioon, vaan ilmoittavat, että minä lähden, että pääministeri vaihtuu.
Mutta Suomessa roikutaan vallassa viimeiseen tinkaan asti, ja seli, seli, seli.
Niin, kyllä pitäis tämän poliittisen päätöksenteon muuttua, uudistua, toden teolla, että ei tämmösiä henkilöitä valita, jotka ei osaa muuta kuin selittää.
Höh, avaatkaa päättäjät jo silmänne, ja nostakaa katseenne ohi sen kaljatuopin, jota te katselette.
Taas tänä päivänä tuli uutisissa ilmoitus siitä, kuinka retuperällä vanhusten huolto on, ja nyt se suu pois siitä oluttuopista, ja jatkakaa.
Va juu, kuus, koska Heikki roittelee tämmöttistä asioista, ko...
Eikö naisille voisi tehdä, ko Suomessa varuskuntijakin tyhjänä on ollut, ainakin niitä laitettiin kiinni, ni tuo...
Naisille tehdä oma varuskunta.
Se olis mun mielestä asialista touhua, ja tuo...
Jos kerran ne halmaa armeijas olla, ni semmonen, semmonen kyllä varmaa voisi järjestyä, niitä on...
Kauha vallakin on lennuston tiloja.
Sitte opetusministerille, sille ruotsalaisten, ni saan semmoteen jutun, että kyllä kannattais luontokirja ottaa uuden kerran käyttöön, että ko...
Mä kuuli sen otteen tapauksen, ja varmaan on tosikin, ni koululaisia pyydettiin tuomaan koivunoksia, ne meniste hakeen, ja ne toi haavanoksia, sitte, että kyllä kannattais hiukan kattoo sitestä koulutustakin, mitä opeteta on, että...
Näitä kieliä opeteta on liian paljo, ruotsinkielta kihan turhan päälle, ko... Suomee mäki osaa, mutta...
Vähä huonosti sitaki, että tuo...
Tunnustan kyllä sen, että...
Kyllä hiukan tarvitsi katsella, mitä... mitä tehdä.
Ei muuttako hyvää jatkoa teille koko väelle sinne.
Juu, kiitos.
Päivää, että pätkähtää. Se on tuo hallitus leikannut kaikesta muusta, mutta ei omista palkoistaan. Et silviisi.
Hyvin erilaista ehdotusta ja hyvin erilaista vinkkiä otetaan mielellään vastaan tänne Kansanradioon. Minäpä voin tuossa hetken kuluttua luetella niitä yhteystietoja, niän on huomattavasti helpompi niitä vinkkejä ja ehdotuksia laittaa.
Kunnyt on ensiksi vaan kuunneltu ja kuultu jo saapuneita ehdotuksia ja vinkkejä. Mikä jottei kehotuksiakin.
Yksi viesti tullut Jarilta.
Nyt, kun on vaikeat ajat ja ihmisiä, päättyy myös ulosottoon jatkuvasti, välillä ilman omaa syytä.
Esimerkiksi ei ole työtä, tai ei ole halua tehdä töitä, koska ulosotto vie kolmasosan vähintään, eikä jätä kuin sen, että juuri ja juuri pärjää.
Eikö tuon ulosoton korot ole ihan vastuuttomasti?
Eli ulosotot kokonaan pois, niin olisi töihin meni joitakin varmasti enemmän.
Kuka sitä ilman palkkaa töitä tekee, kun ei tule kuin rupia käsiin ja takapuoleen? Plus mieleen pahat ajatukset.
Tällaisen viesti laittanut siis Jari, hoitotyötä tekevä, sairaseläkkeellä oleva ulosoton uhri, jonka omaishoidon tuestakin ulosotto vie osansa.
Kansaradio.
No terve.
Terve.
Kansalaisille, että kun tämä kansaradio on, että liittykää puolueeseen.
Liittykää siis poliittiseen puolueeseen.
Että siinä silmät kummasti avautuu, että miten siellä taustalla valtaa käytetään.
Ja ku tässä tänään oli herras henkilö, joka tästä puhui.
Niin liittykää, kattokaa pari vaalikauden ajan sitä touhua, ja jos ei enää kiinnosta, niin lähtekää.
Mutta kyllä se silmiä avaa.
Millä tavalla avaisi silmiä sitten? Miten ihmisen käsitys tai käytös muuttuu, jos liittyisi puolueeseen?
Tota, no just ehkä näkee sitä valtaa, mitä siellä kulisseissa käytetään.
Ja miten just näitä eri tehtäviä jaetaan.
Tänäänkin kansaradiossa oli kyllä aika paljon kansalaiset jotenkin käsitti, että puolueet on yhtä kuin poliitikot, mutta että poliitikothan on hyvin pieni osa siitä puoluetoiminnosta.
Ja ne fiksuimmat yleensä on just siellä taustalla, koska ne tietää, että siellä ne pystyy vetää niistä.
Okei, siellä pystyy vetelemään naruista ilman, että saa sitten kansakunnan mahdolliset.
Viiata päälle?
Jo, just näissä.
Okei, sinnekö tässä nyt sitten pitää pyrkiä?
No, en tiedä, mikä nyt ketäki kiinnostaa, mutta sille, että jos haluaa vähän nähdä tätä touhua sieltä taustalta, niin suonittelen kyllä.
Kesiripun taakse katsomaan, joo, joo, joo.
Hei, mainia juttu, ku soitit, minä kiitän puhelusta.
Kiitoksia.
Toivota hyvät päivät jatkot.
Samoin, hei.
Samoista soittelen, kun tuota, noita paristoja, nuissa lamppuloissa, radioissa, kaikissa, niitä on useita.
Ja olen niitä mitaannut, kun olen poistanut, kun loppunut radiosta, virta, tai lampusta.
Mutta, siinä on semmoinen tilanne, että vain ensimmäinen paristo sieltä viimeistä sieltä päästä menee tyhjäksi, ja muut saattaa olla melkein täysiä.
Tämmönen juttu, että kannattaa nyt vähän niinkun, minun mielestäni tämä on aikamoinen, kansallinen juttu, että säästö, jos näin toteutetaan tää asia, että kokeilla, että onko niissä virtaa niissä paristoissa. Kiitos.
No, Jukka, hei täällä. Hei ollen huolestani joidenkin teiden asfaltifirmojen puolesta, tai oikeastaan tiereunojen laitosta.
Joillakin näköjään tapana laittaa karkeata sepelia niin paljon, että se jopa yrittää asfaltireunan. Tämä aiheuttaa sen, että varsinkin kurveissa, joissa porukkaa ajaa, niin sanottu aikamoilla, tietä, sora lentää asfaltille.
Tää on kuin tappotuomio motoristille, jotka joutuvat kallistamaan pyöreä kurveissa. Silloin se on sama kuin ajaisi teräskuulien päällä.
Voisiko mahdollisesti tienlaittaa käyttää hienoppaa materiaalia siinä, esimerkiksi kivituhkaa?
Piiip, olen valmis. Nyt te kehityskelpoinen idea, kelle insinöörille nyt laittais tämmönen kuin, aintä tölkkejä kuin on, niin sinnehän jää aina helmi vähän pohjalle, vaikka sitä kuinka ravistais vähän pitempääkin.
Nyt tehtäs semmonen homma, ku se aukko on siinä, no ei niitähän reunaa.
Nyt, jos joku insinööri kehittäis semmosen tölkin, että se avaamis aukkoon, se reuna ois ihan lähellä sitä, ihan sitä kynnysreunaa, niin sinne ei jäis helmeä, ja sinne ei jäis siihen päälle olevaa juomaakaan.
Elikkä nyt insinööt hommii, ja kehitetää tölkki, tölkin avaamiskohtaan, ihan lähellä reunaa, niin sinne ei jää helmeäkä sisälle, ja otetaan kaikki juomat, koti. Kiito, Jukka ima rata, moi moi.
Eihän meillä oo täällä mitää hätää, vaikka kaikki vaikeroi.
Eikä oo mitää hätää.
No, eihän meillä oo mitää hätää.
Loppujen lopuksi, jos ajattelee koko maailmaa.
On paljon huonomminkin asiat monessa maassa.
Suomi on hyvinvointivaltio kautta huonovointivaltio.
Millä tavalla me muuten olla huonovointivaltio?
No, me eläämme ylivarojen, se on, se on, pappaki sanoo mulle, että ostetaan, jos on varaa.
Mutta, kun me, me, kansantalous elää velaalla, ja silti puhutaan vaan hylivointivaltio, se on pahavointivaltio,
me syömme ja tuhlamme rahaa enemmän, ku tuotamme.
Meidän pitää elää sen mukaa, ja ottaa tänne sen verran porukkaakin, ku meillä on varaa maksaa.
Eihän, ei velaalla voi elää, suomikaa, se tulee, stoppi.
Kuka se maksaa sen velan? Meidän lapset, meidän lapsen lapset, ei, se voi näin mennä.
Nyt, kun on vähän tällaista laskusuudannetta, niin, tällaista, sanot siis, että tällaista se joskus on,
meidän vaan pitää sopeutua tähän aikaan.
Meidän pitää sopeutua ja jakaa rahaa sen mukaan, ku meillä on kassessa.
Jos on, muullakin säästöporsalista tyyhytää käännetty alaspäin, niin enhän minä voin mitää ostaa, enkä kellekkään mitää hyvinvointia jakaa.
Nii, ja sitten, kun on kassan pohjalla vähän enemmän kolikoita, niin sitten voi...
No, sitten voi sanoa naapurilikitta, mennäänpä terassille kahville.
Näi, just.
Joo, sellaista viestiä, sanoma, ihan koko Suomen kansalle.
No, tää on koko Suomen kansalle, että, sitten vielä toinen asia, niin meidän nämä yritysten perustamani on tehty liian vaikeiksi.
Nikun nämä startup-yrityksetkin, niin helvettii hyviä ideoita, mutta kaikki menee tuonne rapakontaan ja muualle.
Siellä lupien hakeminen vie muutaman kuukauden, rahoitus on siinä ja homma alkaa pöyriä.
Eli byrokratian takia katoaa hyvät ideat ja veroeurot tuonne jonnekin.
Juuri näin.
Painavaa sanaa, minä kiitän tästä puhelusta.
Kyllä juuri näin, ei muuta kuin kaikille suomalaisille vaan hyvää kesää ja reipasta mieltä, kyllä tästä selvitään porukalla.
Kiitos paljonko soitit.
No nii, heila.
Kiitos, moi.
Vielä ennen kirjaimellista loppuvihellystä tai loppuviheltelyä, muutama pähkinä puurutavaksi, eli kysymyksiä esitellään.
Niitä ennen puolestaan, meidän yhteystiedot.
Whatsapp-numero tänne se on 044 55 154 64.
Meidän vastaajanumero puolestaan 08 00 154 64.
Ihmisvastaaja, tällä viikolla Lasse niminen, paikalla kolmen tunnin ajan, heti lähetyksen jälkeen.
Ka, jos sähköpostin muuten haluat laittaa, niin sitten osoitteeseen kansan.radio@yle.fi.
Ja tietysti, jos haluaa kirjoittaa kirja ja kortin, sellaista otetaan vastaan mielellään myös.
Osoite on kansanradio, PL 79 000 24, yleisradio.
Kas, näin.
Jalkapallon MM-kisatkin ne on pian kisailtu, mutta eihän meillä nyt pitäisi tässä sen suurempaa hätää olla tai tulla.
Kekseliäitä ja luovia aikuisia, kun ollaan, niin eiköhän me ideoida jotain tekemistä loppukesäksi.
Vaikkapa sitten mahdollisuuksien mukaan vapaa-ajalla tapahtuvaa löhöilyä.
Ajoittain vapaa-ajalla tapahtuva löhöily on maidio kesäharrastus.
Lasse Olkinuora toivottaa oikein hyvää päivänjatkoa.
No hei, tässä on yks sysmäläine, tältä sysmän suunnasta.
Mä ihmetelisin vaan sitä, että ku tota sysmätietä, joka menee sysmänkeskustaan,
saako semmoinen, jokuin monttutie, mitä ajellaa, autot kärsii ja kaikki kärsii.
Oks se sysmän kunta niin huono, ettei se saa yhtää tietä laitettua.
Paremmalla tielläki ois kiveimpi ajella, yks sysmäläinen, tässä vaan oo vähän vittultunut sen tientät, ja kiitos vaan ja näkemii.
Jussi tässä, miten tämmönen terroristi eristät ne jalkapallojoukkoet vi ovat vielä Suomessa olla esiintyvää Lahdessakin?
Eiks poliisin pitäis pidähtää kaikkia, kattoo niitten rekisteristöt, löytyyks sieltä terroristeja ja tämmösiä, milloin tuomioita oikeudes kylää?
Hälsinkiläisilt joukkoet löytyy ainakin, tai talahtalaisiltki löytyy, et lopetetaan tommoset joukkoet, ja ne ei saa perustaisimmosta enää, ja valtion tuki tämmöselle terrorijärjestölle, eli jalkapallojoukkoelle, lopetettava, et se ois kaikista paras, et saatais rauha maaha.
Papaus, vihillen, la, he, he, he, he.